one of my favorite conversations to have
with anybody if we're getting into deep
real deep type of conversations is look
if you had one thing to teach your kids
what would it be if you had one thing
not seven things not twenty-two keys to
success three keys to a happy life I'm
talking one thing what would it be one
thing if you have one thing what would
it be so for me I have a four year old
and I have a two year old and my four
year old son and my two year old son
they're there watching daddy and there's
so many things I can teach these guys
right I have another one on the way my
wife and I are expecting a daughter
right now is our third one but as a
parent I think if I had the one
conversation with my kids and I'm going
to tell them one thing what would it be
because in life I've always been so
curious to talk to people and folks who
have built big businesses big franchises
big families healthy fact what was the
one thing what was the one thing what
was the one thing what was the one thing
and I've heard so many of them so many
more over the years that for me from all
the study enough done I've come out with
one thing this is the one thing above
all that's the most important thing that
I plan on teaching my kids that also I
strive to teach people that I mentor as
entrepreneurs because I have yet found
to have one thing be above this now let
me tell you what some of the things that
you and I've heard about when you ask
people and say what's the one thing many
of us have heard some people say well
you got to learn to control your
emotions it's more important than
anything else okay it's a good point you
got to take care of your health because
your Health's got to come before your
wealth make sense very valid you got to
learn how to hustle and make money sure
you got to learn how to love people you
hear that one a lot love is the most
important thing love is this love is
that great no problem you gotta have a
relationship with God you got to do what
you love right you got to work hard all
valid all great but is it the one thing
some may say God is the one thing you
know integrity is the one thing work for
nonprofit one thing give back money
isn't everything
gratitude save your virgin
respect marry the right person all valid
pray meditate read discipline stay in
school avoid drugs and alcohol so far
everything makes sense compassionate
care about people give back slow down a
little bit in life don't follow the
majority all of this stuff they're all
good things but what is the one thing to
me it's the one thing what's the one
thing you know I don't know when I first
got started in business I was so
overwhelmed because this person would
say do this do this do this do this do
that I was all over the place I asked
what's the one thing I don't want 17
things what's the one thing and I'll
never forget the one thing I got in
business and that became like absolute
obsession people ask me today what's
your one thing and in business you know
what's the one thing in this so to me
the one thing to teach your kids or do
one thing for you to master comes out to
this
the one thing and the one thing all of
this goes within that one thing and
that's what it is let me tell what it is
the one thing is for you and I to learn
how to process issues that's the one
thing you see if a person learns how to
process issues that person generally
ends up becoming a president a governor
a CEO of a company a head coach for a
team a head coach for an organization it
doesn't matter people who lead larger
organizations they learn how to process
issues now you may say Pat what do you
mean process issues are you telling me
processing issues as above all of this
yes what do you mean by that let's
explain to watch this if a person knows
how to process issues when you and I are
absolutely furious with somebody or some
happens in the mind while you're
irritating and you want to tell them off
if you know how to process issues here's
how you go through and you say if I tell
her this and she's going to come back
and say this and it's going to go back
and say this then I'm going to leave a
mark and she's going to get upset I'm
going to get upset I'm not going to
sleep good our relations not going to be
good we're not going to talk for the
next two three months four months five
months what if my kids do this to me
you're just going to go deep with it and
you just say I'm gonna stay quiet now
this is if we learn how to do this
processing issues to health if you learn
how to process issues you're gonna say
my backwards why is my back hurt my
ankle hurts what does my ankle hurt
why is my why is my energy why am i
sleeping and sewing maybe I'm not
exercising enough maybe I need to get my
damn eating too much sweets I'm eating
too many burgers but it's all back to
processing issues hustle if you're
struggling financially you don't have
any money you're gonna sit there and say
oh I don't have any money why is it that
were broke why is it that we don't live
in a nice place why I said we have no
money in place am i working hard enough
I don't watch so much TV why is it that
everybody I talked on all those TV shows
that are going on you know MBA
housewives I know CSI mall were telling
you shows in the park I don't watch a
lot of shows you know I know every
single event I know everything I watch
every single basketball game in it I
know too much of I'm not hustling enough
if you process your hustle love what is
love what am i my relationship is going
bad why is my relation with my dad not
that good why is my rush my friends not
that was my rush my girlfriend my boy
from my husband my wife my kids not that
good my lovin and what is love is love
just a feeling is it there my wife keeps
telling me you don't tell me you love me
anymore I told her that well love is
something you already should know that I
love you it's not that I have to tell
you I love you give me a break I - I
married you already I've given your life
you should already know I love you but
then she tells me no you don't show that
you love me so what is love let me go
research what is love what is really
love oh love is an action love is a verb
so love is a verb am i showing love and
I need to start showing so what do I do
when's the last time I bought of flowers
were six years ago I need to send a
dozen roses then you'll learn how to
love because you process the issue of
what love is God you know what I don't
believe in God now let me tell you
something happen very strange dear that
when I was saying this and I did say no
what I'm going to try now and try to see
if this prayer stuff works and I'm gonna
go out there and do this and is it
really a God if there isn't a god I read
this you know that Religulous video that
came out by Bill Moore and he's all
about there is no God and he goes and he
calls these people out the Catholic
Church and they talk about this this
this is and all the way in and I heard
this other guy to talk about Scientology
and do this and I wonder may Mormon so
which one is it the Jehovah's Witness
seven they add mine's a Christian
Catholic Mormon which one do I go with
is it but should there be a gun there's
an economy P man Creek did man create
the earth who created or is it a sin
that turn into human so are we in
evolution from the you know gorillas to
this onto one so but if you're curious
then eventually you're going to figure
out that there is probable
higher power order isn't for you because
you're learning how to process issues if
I just tell my kid you ought to believe
in God because of X Y Z you should
believe in God and go to church I'm on a
foursome he's not going to want to do it
instead I'm going to tell him tell me
where your questions are about it once
you go research it and come up with all
the different arguments so I'm going to
teach the kid how to think I want to
teach to get how to process the issue if
I so many times kids are forced to be
raised in a church they don't want to
even want to touch it anymore it's force
I'd rather have you process the issue
so who's this Jesus guy DubLi - Jesus
guy do you think it's real
maybe it's fake maybe he's a maniac
maybe it's not real what do you think
about this other guy Joseph Smith guy
what do you think about the Dianetics
guy you know anything about this guy l
ron Hubbard what do you think about this
other guy you know Bo Halle what do you
think about this mohammed gut he met
this prophet guy what do you know about
him you seen there's why did all these
guys talk about God what is this 10
commandments all about it's a really
legit this is learning how to process
issues if there is a sense of curiosity
I can teach somebody I'll process issues
they'll eventually come to conclusion
here do what you love do much Allah
process issues am I really is it truly
about me doing what I love or what is me
loving is like something out of
conversation with somebody the other day
and says you know when I just don't know
if I love this anymore and I said what
is this he says what do you mean I said
you said you don't love this anymore so
what is this he says I don't understand
a question it's okay you don't love this
anymore what is this and he says well
this is insurance and financial services
I said that's this to you because that's
not what this is to me says what do you
mean I said do you love people oh I
think so I said so do you do this
business because the product is it so
you think you're going to go do real
estate follow up with bricks you think
you're going to go to pharmaceutical
sales and fall in love with medicine so
what is this redefine what this means to
you to me this means people and I love
people I'm curious about people so every
day I get to work I'm touching people
and learning about people I'm so curious
about that all I never thought about it
that way before
so we processed it together now he's
high on life he is completed from place
because we processed what it meant do I
still love what I'm doing because
processing issue
again is the number one thing to learn
working hard should I work hard should I
not work out it's a processing issue
integrity what if I like to this person
I should probably lie to this person but
if I like to this person what if that
other personalized to me what if I like
to this person now and later on we have
a relationship and then they find out
that I lie to them and the next thing
and I'm getting a divorce do I want to
get a divorce after having three kids
and then I have to do child custody all
this other stuff that's better off mine
online I just better be open with them
right now so I don't have to worry about
the headache integrity I'm doing
business with their person what if I
like to just partner right and I tell
them I really don't have anything
because if I tell them I don't have any
anything then I have a power-play
because I tell them I need a bigger
salary because if he knows that I have
more money and then later on he finds it
then I lose the partner do I want to
have that this is integrity of
processing issues if you know how to
process issues there is not a lot of
value on lining so you'll learn a few
process issues next working for
nonprofit why would I want to help give
people money back I work for that money
should I give the money back
well maybe this money I mean somebody
help me out when I was younger it
somebody help me me you know but I want
to give back it feels good when I don't
teach my kids to also give back because
if you hold on to it you lose what you
already have if you give it back it
comes back I want to give back let me
see how this feels oh my god I felt so
good giving back processing issues money
isn't everything this money really not
everything my mom keeps telling me mom
money is not everything money's not
everything but honestly I watched my mom
and dad go through the war so if money
wasn't everything why is it that day
night all they argued about wars over
money but now that I have money I don't
think money is everything but it allows
me to use it as a tool to do other
things in my life so is it really that
that you go deeper into it for every one
of these things gratitude save your
virginity respect marry the right I mean
I'm giving you what people given me
these are answers that they're giving me
these are not my answers this is what
other people are gonna say said marry
the right person it's processing issues
this is purely processing issues praying
metadata reading somebody asked me why
should I read we process that issue
together they said oh this makes sense
why does it make sense to be disciplined
process that issue stay in school
is it truly to stay in school for me why
would I want to go to school so the
whole episode we did on stay in school
or drop out and I've got more
controversy and fortune wrote an article
about a business insider wrote an
article about a bunch of people called
us to do blogs you know podcasts all
these other things Pat
you really believe 80% of kids you drop
out of school yes
I go watch the video 80% should drop out
yes
80% should drop out of college pad
you're crazy saying that never said I'm
not crazy but that's how I process the
issue I don't agree with you watch it
then tell me if you agree with me or not
can we put the picture that so they know
which one it is and where to find it the
link on the bottom as well
processing issues avoiding drugs why is
avoiding drugs somebody asked me to set
down and talk to a couple young guys and
this guy says well I like to smoke weed
and I see you like to smoke weed I so
tell me why this is why you know some of
the greatest minds smoke pot I said tell
me to uh people that smoke pot oh you
know this guy music art in I said what
business are you nice I'm a business
what type of business sales and other
that's it you want to smoke weed and
smoke pot and be in business so what
happens when you smoke pot what do you
think it does to you
slows you down it does this is des
that's it are you musician do you write
music do you do this what do you do so
what are you trying to smoke pot for we
processed it together so let's just say
it doesn't make sense to smoke pot what
would it make sense to smoke pot well
you know what but Steve Jobs said you
got two ls thing you got we process that
together this other person's you got and
all these misconceptions that they've
read in an article that you got to do
this and you got to do that that process
the issue is it make sense to do that
what I want to do steroids why do you
wanna do steroids because I want to go
out and compete and you know I won't do
this okay I mean if you want to compete
and you want to do you know get at the
highest level you don't just need to do
steroids you need to go and grow through
them and all the but do you know the
consequence with your body are you okay
with that's processing issues you know I
don't want to I want to do because I'm
going to look at for summertime it
doesn't make sense to do this just for
body types of processing issues
compassionate giving back slowing down
don't follow the majority all of this is
processing issues which I call this the
number one thing is learning how to
learning how to solve for X if you work
for me you'll hear me talking about this
all the time let's solve for X what's X
the more you look at life like this
everything becomes a formula because
everything's about solving for x that's
really what life is all about I talked
to a few kids the other day they came up
here I was in LA Van Nuys doing
a few kids came up to me and every time
this kid comes up to me I really like
talking to this kid
his mom was standing up so listen you
remember what you and I talked about
last time seven eight nine year old kid
so do you remember you and I talked
about last missus yes I do what I say to
you last time and this was like five
months ago he says you told me pay
attention to math I said are you paying
more attention to math he said yes and I
said here's why math is important math
is not necessarily about you know
Pythagorean theorem all the some math is
about figuring out the formula for life
math teaches you how to process issues a
lot of times when somebody says I just
cannot stand math life is math
everything about life is man if you look
at math as a life as a mathematical
formula you start solving problems
everything becomes math everything
becomes mad so if you look at marriage
as a mathematical formula health ISM as
a mathematical formula you try to figure
out ways how to solve that
that's processing issues geometry the
whole cpctc theorem that's of processing
issues all the X plus y equals Z or
whatever it is that's processing issues
yet every one of those things is
processing issues so I'm sitting here
and I'm telling you all this stuff about
processing issues some people ask well
how do I become better at processing
issues what if I want to become better
at processing issues is there a formula
to it yes there's a formula to it I'm
not going to get into all the formula
here today what I will be doing there'll
be a series of processing issues that
I'll be taking a subject okay marriage
and I'm going to do an episode of
processing issues marriage and we're
going to do a 60 minute episode on how
to process issues for marriage should I
get married or shall not get married
we're going to take money and we're
going to process issues for money how to
make the money why to make the money
should you make the money who I care to
make the money is there value for the
money really processing the issue both
emotionally and logically and going so
deep into it that you could make an
educated decision saying this is why I'm
making money here's why I'm doing it for
and I know why I'm not just doing it
because the whole world is me let me go
make 100 million bucks for what what are
you making a hundred million bucks for
so there is a formula on how to process
issues but if you look back historically
quickly and you think about think about
the greatest minds of all time Socrates
you got I believe with Socrates Plato
Aristotle Alexander I think it is
Socrates Plato Aristotle Alexander
Socrates mentors Plato Plato works with
Aristotle Aristotle mentors Alexander
Alexander conquers 2 million square
miles of the world they what did they
really pass to each other what was it so
we call it philosophy what is philosophy
it's a way of thinking what is way of
thinking it's really about processing
issues when Seneca comes out with
stoicism and Marcus Aurelius who is the
Empire of Rome I think from 60 to 80 to
69 some seven years is what he is and he
takes stoicism Seneca dies because he
had to kill himself for what they were
going to do to him and Seneca takes that
and Marcus Aurelius takes stoicism he
starts teaching roam about stoicism and
people start being more responsible
logical it changes the way of thinking
and now that has an evolution a thousand
years later 2,000 years later people are
still teaching stoicism
today as a way of thinking but there was
somebody that taught others how to think
if you read the book one of my favorite
books to read meditations by Marcus
Aurelius
I like the Gregory is it Gregory Hayes
edition I think it's called the Gregory
Hayes I don't know if I have it here
anyways if you message me I'll message
you back with the with the which one I'm
talking I think so Gregory Hayes
translation of Marcus Aurelius
meditations it's priceless he teaches
you what he learned from his mom what he
learned from his dad what he learned
from his grandfather what he learned
everything about his life and about 90
pages he explains it it's a brilliant
book to read but it's teaching how to
think teaching how to process issues
this sooner politically what is politics
when I sit down and talk to somebody and
they have such a strong opinion about
politics I'll ask them a question I said
let me ask you this let you say I give
you the best argument right now about
what your beliefs here are you open to
changing no way I don't have an energy
to talk to you about it for what for
what what's the point
I said now fight if I challenge this
position and you and I talk about it and
you disagree are you going to start
name-calling or can we really have a
dull commerce say no no
going to be okay five minutes
centralizing and getting edged ensign
let's change the conversation forget
about Paula what's go to sports but it's
processing issues and if you if you if
you truly and I'm telling you this
listen Evan I've made so many mistakes
in my life and I don't have all the
answers far from it
I am still I'm only 37 years old
learning for myself to get more clarity
in life but if there is one thing that
gives me peace if there's one thing that
gives me peace is there is the one skill
set that I strive to get better in life
is processing issues hiring and firing
people is processing issues finding an
investor that's an active or passive
investor it's processing issues deciding
how the equity is going to be given up
as processing issues deciding the amount
of money that's going to be paid to
somebody's processing issues
compensation plans payouts negotiations
with carriers why partnering up with
this carrier that's processing issues
why this carrier doesn't make sense why
this vendor doesn't make sense why
moving to Texas why stay in California
why pursue this why do that everything
is processing issues why should we favor
this person at this point of his career
on what he's doing is he really loving
what we're doing are we going to make
that this is this person only about
themselves it's processing issues what
is the trend with this person what is a
trend with this state what is a trend
with this market it's not the fact that
you have to learn a million things what
you're learning is throw me is and by
the way this becomes exciting because
anytime that our staff we have lunch
together this is typically what I'll do
I'll take the most random video that's
subject like right now Google today what
was that one thing Atlas the Atlas robot
what is called the Atlas what was
something right I don't know what it's
called Scott Atlas Boston Dynamics which
is a company owned by Google launches
the first robot if you haven't seen the
video I highly recommend you go watch
the video it's called Atlas something
anyway it's very very interesting you
see the Atlas they're kicking him
they're hitting him he falls down he
gets back up
it's called Atlas the next generation
very interesting so what do you do with
that very simple hey what do you think
about this what do you mean what do I
think about this you think really the
iRobot is going to
place you think we're eventually going
to have a terminator you think
eventually robots are going to take over
the world you think there's going to be
an uprise with robots and all this other
stuff and then you talk about it what
will be their limits with the robots how
could the government control the robots
well people by robots will people be
replaced by robots why would people not
be replaced by robots the muscle of
processing issues is working that's what
you're doing it for it's how I can't
believe that Oh Momo Momo Momo Momo Momo
Momo the brain is learning how to
process issues my job as a CEO of PHP
agency' a financial firm is to teach our
leaders how to process issues our
competitors watch a lot of our content
and our competitors will say how we have
an edge on whatever I have a feeling
work this is why we're not afraid oh
this is a summer comparison so here when
he goes up to next what is that thing
I'm hearing about you guys are doing
well first of all competitors are not
really going to know everything we're
working on some of them so why do you
even produce this content for everybody
else well this is what we're doing we're
freely sharing the information out there
with other people but you're not
necessarily going to know everything you
you got to know there are some things
that we have a team here that's projects
that we're working on that not everyone
is going to know about because it goes
back to processing issues because a part
of processing issues is about strategies
and the type of strategies you put in
place and some of them maybe it's like
you have zero attention on your
competition because your attention is
purely on what you want to do to develop
something that's never been developed
from what is that what is that strategy
that you have and the people that you
work with typically sit there and say I
buy into this concept this makes sense
let's processor together so again going
back to it that guys started off talking
about my two boys my two boys that I
love dearly you know any second I have
with these guys it's heaven to me when
they're around me they're wrestling with
me they're jumping on top of me daddy
daddy daddy daddy daddy
that's heaven to me and as a
responsibility of a father I have I have
no idea how much more living I have to
do I have no idea much more live enough
to do if I can teach these kids how to
process issues and then I'm dead and
they learn how to teach their kids how
to process issues and then their kids
learn how to teach their kids how to
process issues then that's a tradition
you're creating and I think the reason
why America as a country did so well is
because many many generations ago we
taught each other how to process issues
and the country kept on evolving getting
better Rockefeller taught the next
entrepreneurs how to process issues then
you had you know a chase and you had
Carnegie then you had all of these guys
that kept teaching how to process issues
and that's one of the reasons why I've
given birth to so many incredible
entrepreneurs around the world that are
doing better than the original founder
run entrepreneurs why because everyone's
learning on how to process issues from
the prior generation and I think the
more we give back there are many ways to
be able to make a better world a better
country better life for our kids for
yourself for myself more exciting more
intense but it's going back to the one
skill of how to process issues and so
stay tuned because we're going to be
doing many more D series that you'll see
the word solve for x solve for x and
solve for x we'll be around the subject
of processing issues and so if you have
any subjects that you say Pat I wouldn't
mind processing these issues together
here's the subjects that I have that
we're going to go through let me give
you some of them here marriage money
career your calling sex politics health
overcoming your own vice drugs those are
some of the ones that we have in place
faith political friend versus
acquaintances
I've already done the school fun having
kids not having kids what to learn those
are processing issue subjects that we'll
do but if there are any one of them that
you specifically want to recommend tweet
me private message me comment on the
bottom here this is a series that's
going to continue as we choose a subject
to process together and it would be
almost like you're not in a classroom
together and we're getting a whole oh
not chalkboard I don't know what we're
putting you we're putting something here
that's bigger because we are still
transitioning we're moving all our stuff
from California to Texas so some of the
stuff is showing up some of the stuff is
custom our studio is about to be build
up so a lot of these things are coming
but you will see that we will sit there
and literally as if you and I are
sitting in a classroom together it's 2
o'clock at night in the morning you're
watching this we're going to sit there
and process and
together for the next few months to come
and I continuously plan on doing this as
long as you have subjects that you want
to process together that's a bigger
subject of life we'll be constantly
looking into doing that together so
again if you have any questions about
what we talked about today comment on
the bottom post your questions on the
bottom if you have other people that you
think a subject like this would interest
share this video with them and talk
about this allow this conversation to
lead into the muscle of processing
issues getting better and then if you
haven't subscribe to our channel value
thema please do so on youtube and even
if you watch this on different networks
entrepreneur network or some of the
different channels that I put this my
channel is value tainment on youtube you
can subscribe to that channel and if you
want to go to my website to get more
content Patrick video VidCon there's a
there's a ton of content over there they
can find with that being said thanks for
watching